y'all need to respect the Marquee of
death Clyde wincham this guy is a
wrecking ball on a Multiverse level
check this out this guy has the ability
to manipulate and change reality at will
including creating and destroying whole
universes he has the ability to travel
between parallel universes instantly he
can effortlessly destroy any Universe he
comes across he has the ability to use
or create high abstract or higher
dimensional entities as puppets in his
matches against a Fantastic Four and he
has the ability to control beings on the
level of Eternity the highest level of
cosmic entity in any one Universe with
the greatest of ease make sure you guys
follow for more